[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I sort of know things like I knew I find
you
I intend to find out the truth about my
family one way or another
[Applause]
audience and that the entirety of that
Global audience see themselves reflected
it allows us to tell some stories that
are not traditionally told on screen and
these powerful characters are integral
to the foundation Saga
season one Gale is very young and
learning season two she's a lot more in
control
I understand and right now we just need
to accept that I've found a lot more
confidence this season I look at myself
in those First episodes in season one
and look at some of the stuff I'm doing
now and I can't quite believe that it's
the same person and it's me so it is so
fun to watch myself grow as much as Gail
my name
self or hardened I'm your daughter
I definitely wanted her to be somebody
that people looked up to it's nice to
play somebody who's got a really
wholesome heart and real determination
in season one she's not very confident
about the things that make her different
but I'm season two she's gone through
metamorphosis of appreciating the
differences and seeing strengths in them
never let your sense of morals prevent
you from doing what's right
Gail unexpectedly is reunited with this
daughter that she didn't know she had
and her daughter salver is biologically
older than she is finding out she has a
daughter dealing with the fact that she
hasn't raised her daughter there's so
many factors that are affecting the way
that she is trying to interact with Sobo
it's not the rosie reunion that one
would expect they've got to earn that
relationship I will always be here as I
always have been
in season two we start to explore
damersel's relationship to Empire is she
a captive or a captor is she actually
pulling the strings of Empire we see
them result leading day where she wants
to end we get to see a little glimpse of
how much power she holds over him
she dreams of freedom and at the same
time her programming prevents her from
that dream coming true that conflict is
haunting I'm left to wander
it's directive would my feelings be the
same would I feel anything
[Applause]
there are a lot of new characters who
are going to change the course of the
show will you serve me I will serve
Empire Queen sarath has been chosen by
day to be his bride she brings a lot of
feminine power and energy into
is a very male dominated space
we all said he can steamroll over her
but she turns out to be quite a deaf
political operative who really gives him
a run for his money it's just the
Classic case of never touch a book by
its cover just because a woman comes in
wearing high heels and a flirty dress
doesn't mean she's not going to ruin
your life
should I speak first or will you
constant brother constant is a novice in
the Church of the galactic Spirit she
bounces around the galaxy in the outer
reach trying to evangelize the people to
the way of the foundation she's got a
real sense of who she is and I think
people sort of mistake her as a young
girl
she's not at all she doesn't take any
crap from anyone
is an antagonist we created for the
series she will do whatever it takes for
eternal life you are singular Gail
dornick she's never come across anybody
as powerful as Gail who can see the
future she may be a villain she may not
be a villain buckle up season two is
incredible it really feels that David
and the team have just thrown everything
at this series do it
there's so many amazing people this
season the casting in the storyline is
perfect and I just can't wait to share
it with everyone
we will be ready
[Music]